好 我们的直播开始啦
我在这个群里宣传一下
哈喽 哈喽
我们今天这个
安量斯的一些新款
直播
稍微等一下哈
刚刚开播今天
以后我们周六的这个
安量斯每期的直播
就稍微晚一点开哈
因为比如说白天早上啊
什么的还有这个隔壁
平台的播出也是要播
这个牌子所以有时候
如果这个撞到一起的话
我们就会稍微晚一点再开播
或者以后
嗯
早一点开播也可以吧
反正就是和其他的一些博主
就岔开去播比较好哈
这样子
哈喽 哈喽
大家好
安量斯的这个下款直播
然后七月份也是跟大家预告一下
七月二十三号左右是开始有那个
Amy的一个展示会
听说他们这一次的新款
就是有一个联名款哈
是听说就非常好看
所以到时候下周吧
应该是下周是我们就哦
下下周下下周下周是那个Daisy的展示会
下下周是Amy的展示会
我们都会去给大家同时的一个播报哈
今天嗯反正也没有太多的新款
我们差不多把之前没有穿到过的一些颜色啊
还有一些搭配都给大家再过一遍
像我身上这一件这一件比较比较度假风的一条连衣裙
比较度假风的一条连衣裙啊
它是一个吊带裙它背带裙背带裙
然后整体的设计会稍微有一点点像那种
Astera的一个感觉
但是整体上还是会比Astera要再那个
再日常一点再欧雅风一点
就平时上班什么的穿
Aliance还是会更好一点哈
身高体重多少
身高一六五体重四十八公斤
一六五四十八
四十八到四十九啊
四十八到四十九
今天反正也没有太多的新款
所以我们其实过款直播的话不会直播非常久啊
就还是大概的过一下就
我这个刚才一下子袖子
就稍微的给大家过一下
像这个外套我其实也穿了好几次
衬衫推荐什么颜色
我还是会比较推荐白色一点点
但是今天现场就是只有这个深棕色
像夏天嘛
你肯定是白色是最百搭的
比如说我身上里面穿了一个
红却蓝的这个连衣裙嘛
它其实白色是更搭这个颜色
它背后是有这种小绑带的
这绑带呢
我们可以顺势给它系到前面来
衬衫的话我就不按讲解了
因为前几次穿的是那个白色的
我会比较推荐一些
像这样子可以稍微往后搭拉着一点点
像比如说是去度假的姐妹们
这个衬衫还是挺值得
那个15号裙子显胖吗
我看一下
15号裙子
15号那个蛋糕裙是吧
那个反正不显瘦
反正不是显瘦的款式
但穿上去它就没有修身了
但我们待会儿还是可以再稍微去穿一下的
如果是比较介意这种非常A字型
非常蛋糕型的姐妹
就我不太推荐15号
可能更推荐它的同系列的一个半裙
同系列的半裙
我看看是2号链接
因为2号链接就相对于它的面料和那个设计和15号都是完全一样的
所以2号感觉拍的姐妹也会多一点点
像2号今天我们可以搭
这个衬衫不扎
一点都不扎
这个衬衫
但它会有一点点像那种纱质感的一个衬衫
就不是那种棉质感
因为棉质感穿在身上的话呢
身上会是那种很黏柔的一个软软的感觉
这个就会比较像纱的一个效果
扎到是不会扎
就前面的绑带是可以这样子系的
这样子也可以直接系在背后
就相当于是有一个背后式的小收腰
今天就
今天可以给大家多套几套之前没有套过的一些穿搭的方法
2号半裙粉色上衣怎么搭比较好
我给你看一下2号
今天其实2号的话
我觉得今天有好几个上衣可以用来搭它
待会我们都可以分别来试试
分别的试一下
像这个2号之前我是搭了那个三件套的一个上衣
今天感觉可以搭一个这一件
这一件搭吧
上去的话其实就还挺适合夏天通勤的时候穿
这件小上衣也是之前去年卖的还挺好的一个款式
它是下半身
我把外套还是脱掉
我们先把里面的连衣裙给讲了之后
就把这个这一套2号配这个小上衣给讲一下
它这件小上衣的话
下摆处是有一点点像燕子尾巴
就剪刀感的一个这种分叉型的下摆
然后整个面料
是那种非常薄的一个针织面料
是一个针织面料
所以这个款式是比较适合夏天穿的
可能穿在身上如果是浅色系的话
还会有一点点透
像这一件小上衣会显得腰身非常的纤细
因为它是中间给你有一点这种流出来的
流摆的一个感觉
两边就是直接顺着像腰线一样的感觉这样下去
所以这个款式是平衡性的
平时如果喜欢穿下面喜欢穿这种A字型裙的姐妹
我还挺推荐这个小上衣的
它会比其他的一些针织毛衣的材质要更加轻薄一点点
这个是我比较推荐的就是搭2号的一个小上衣
当然大家如果想搭一些更加少女感的一些上衣的话
我们今天也有也有比如说挂脖式的一些上衣
我感觉都可以搭那种西装裤的那种上衣
或者裤裤什么的一起配在一起看看
我们先把身上的这一件连衣裙给大家讲
其实今天所有的款式基本上都有讲到过
反正每次来都是把上一期没有穿到的颜色给大家再过一下
像我现在身上这个款式是9号链接
这个是已经已经有现货的一条连衣裙
但这一条连衣裙
可能大家觉得没有那么日常
所以我感觉拍的人没有就是我们当时卖纽结裙拍的人那么多
像这个款式它整个是比较偏度假风的一个感觉
颜色上是这一期阿尿死
他比较喜欢出的一个颜色就是孔雀兰
像那个15号刚才有姐妹问的15号
他也出了一个新的颜色就是孔雀兰
就也就是我身上这种又蓝
又有点绿的一个颜色
这颜色也是有一点点微妙
就感觉喜欢的人会非常喜欢
但是可能有一些平时不怎么穿这种蓝绿色的衣服的姐妹
就可能不太喜欢这种颜色
但这个颜色有一个好处是
它对于黄皮来说是非常显摆的一个颜色
再就是我身上这一条裙子虽然很长
但是它的这个重量是很轻薄的
基本上就是完全无重量的那种度假裙
前面会有一个倒三角的一个这样子的小镂空设计
这一款呢肩带是可以调节的
胸围是不限制的
而且这个腰围臀围都是不限制的
所以像这个款式对于那些
比如说是早期孕妈妈呀什么的
都是夏天可以穿的毕竟是很凉快
再加上它确实整个穿在身上是
那种很宽松的一个样式
像这个款式如果不想露手臂的姐妹
也可以搭个小外套
想看6号的白色
好的我看一下6号是哪个款式
6号的啊那个小刮脖没问题
没问题6号的白色
6号其实三个颜色我都还挺喜欢
因为像上一次好像穿的是那个薄荷色对吧
直发唇对
我就刚刚做了那个矫正
我就不能去卷发
最近就是不能卷发
因为头发太毛躁
毛躁太毛躁了
所以就做了一个直发的一个效果
这样子一个款式
下一套我们先去穿这个2号
2号穿了之后再去把6号的一个小上衣
再给大家穿一下
这个裙子是印度棉吗
不是它不是那种棉质感
不是棉质感
它是会有一点丝滑的一个质感
印度棉的话会比这个重很多
我不知道有没有姐妹就是有收到印度棉的那些系列
就印度棉的那个半身裙
包括脸衣裙是比较重
因为做工很很重工
再加上印度棉它是棉那个质感
它又用的比较实心
所以那个真的还挺重
当然像我身上这一件就不是棉的一个质感
它是属于这种巨鲜
还有一些人造的那种纤维质的一些种材质
就整个是比较轻薄的一个效果
这一套我们就过掉路
过掉了
我们下一套去试一下
这个2号的一个蛋糕式的半身裙
这一款半身裙和15号的链接是完全一样的材质
包括它的这个蛋糕系列的设计
也都是一样的
就是一个是半身裙一个是连衣裙
所以如果是担心15号比较显胖的姐妹们
我还是比较推荐半身裙
因为这个半身裙去年买的人也是比连衣裙要多一些
也有姐妹
姐妹如果在群内的话也可以问一下
去年有买到过的宝宝们
他们都有反馈过
说这个裙子是比较仙气飘飘的一个半裙
而且可以搭到的机会还是挺多的
可以搭这种稍微有一点设计感的上衣
也可以搭非常简单的那种白色T恤
就是都可以搭
怎么进
宝宝你可以去戳一下我们的客服
戳一下我们的客服
我们Alliance和Amy是专门有一个这个裙的
所以宝宝可以直接去戳一下我们的客服
我们这个半裙和小上衣就给大家去穿一下
大家稍微等我一下
稍微等我一下
代替一下
大的
직
扮
一雙
够了
请不吝点赞订阅订阅
谢谢姐妹帮我们送这个棒棒糖
梳一下头发
太乱了最近
我们讲一下二号链接和这个一号链接的一个效果
一号链接这个也算是一个复刻款了
它是我们去年就是做的
安妞斯做的比较火的一个系列
它就是下半身是做了像这种
小燕子形状的一个小开叉
这样子的开叉式上衣呢
我们下半身的半身裙就可以去
适配一些其他颜色的
这样子中间的颜色就是可以露出来
而且会显得腰围上会比较纤细的一个感觉
给你展示一下
展示
真的有一点
有一点
然后像这个小上衣的话
它的下摆处这个燕子小尾巴的地方
它都是
嗯
都是有蕾丝的一个小拼接的
像这个款式其实搭裤子也好看
会显得整个人很瘦吧
那有我觉得像买一号链接的姐妹
就会比较担心
它这款上衣厚不厚
但反正我是觉得有一些针织是夏天可以穿的
但有一些是夏天很难去
嗯
在室外穿
这款是夏天是可以穿的
它真的非常薄
真的非常薄
如果我们就可惜是
它不是一个浅色
如果是浅色系的话
估计现在是可以已经透出来
里面的这个肤色
反正这个款式呢
就整个有一点点像那种线织衫
不像是针织衫的一个效果
肚皮上的肉肉挺多啊
真的吗
肚皮上的肉肉
这个是16165
身高是16像这个款式
这样子
然后它的
叶下的这个呃
白白肉的地方是可以完全给它遮住的哈
再就是肩带的部分
这样子是直筒下来的
所以如果就比较担心这个白白肉的部分
上衣几个颜色
我给你看一下
还有另一个颜色有在线
哦
有还有白色也进来
还有一个白色纯白色
可能就有一些姐妹觉得像夏天就可能是
浅色系会更加舒适一点点哈
但我感觉像这种针织的系列
深色卖的会比浅色要好一点点
因为深色就首先它是有一个这种素身的一个效果
会比白色就没有那么膨胀嘛
嗯
如果是像T恤衫衬衫类型的
我可能会比较推荐大家选白色
但是像这种针织类型
我还是会推荐深色系
深色系
他首先这个腰上就会让你觉得很瘦
再就是胸围的部分
是呃
这个果然半裙比较显瘦
对半裙肯定是比较显瘦
他这个半裙因为就下面是散开嘛
那你上半身我们去穿一些瘦瘦的上衣就可以了
但是连衣裙的话
他其实从这个胸围这里开始就已经是蛋糕的形式了
就没有办法去收腰
所以像那个连衣裙的话
就如果是比较担心显胖的姐妹
就我建议还是不要去选连衣裙
连衣裙的话怎么样穿都会有一点点像那种大大袍子的一个感觉
他因为从胸围这就开始没有瘦腰
所以那个胸围比较丰满的姐妹穿S码都可以的哈
因为他真的非常非常宽松
棕色能比比吗
没问题
棕色给你比一下
棕色是有一点点像巧克力的一个颜色
给你看一下棕色和黑色
我会比较推荐
比白色的话就是你会有很多其他的选择吧
但像这个针织啊
限制给大家看一下上面有多多透
这个是真的很清凉
他跟因为前几次啊
有一个那个安量斯的拼接针织连衣裙
大家还记得吗
那一款可就是厚了呀
那一件我是不推荐大家夏天购入可以再蹲蹲
如果万一以后
那种比较大的折扣的时候再买
像这个款式呢
他本身就很薄
就是夏天可以穿到的一个限制
裙子腰围是多少
我来帮你看一下哈
这个裙子
我来看一下
裙子的话
我们官网上应该有出现有写那个具体的
腰围
但是我感觉他这个裙子的话
其实我现在穿的是S码
穿的是S码
但是腰围应该是可以穿到六十八左右
六十八左右
就S码的话腰围是可以穿到六十八
那如果你的腰围是在六十八以上的姐妹
我建议去拍M5尺码
大概是这样
他这个裙子还是挺就腰围还是腰围上肯定是比
Amy要更加的宽松一点点
再就是颜色啊
他这个裙子颜色是有带珠光感的哈
整个都是这种粉色的一个珠光感
他这个粉呢
就是有点偏暖色调的粉
所以对于那些黄皮应该像我们黄皮的黄皮的人穿也不会觉得是非常显黑的哈
裙长是多少163穿会脱地吗
不至于到脱地的程度哈
但是应该是会到脚面上方
就不会脱地
但是确实是会到脚面
你看我大概穿的是在这个脚踝盖住了哈
整个脚踝是已经完全盖住了
但还没有到脚面的那个程度
稍微穿了一个种松高鞋
其实也不会脱地
这个裙子他就是主打的是一个比较长
比较鲜
比较飘的这样子一个半身裙
这样的一个效果
看看这小商业我们讲完了
我们来讲一下裙子啊
侧边可以看到我把这个裙子的讲解给大家按一下
裙子是我们二号链接
二号链接其实前几次我搭的是一个那个三件套哈
三件套的小上衣
但其实像这样子搭
我记得去年哈
特别清楚他去年其实就是这样搭
因为这小上衣
他其实弹力什么的都非常完美哦
上衣的弹力忘记跟大家介绍
他这个弹力是
非常大
所以胸围如果你胸围比较大的女生穿一号上衣的话
他会显得腰更瘦
这里是活紧去靴
就是被切开了吗
一个感觉
然后两侧是一个腰线哈
所以这个小上衣我还挺推荐胸围大
然后又要显得腰瘦的姐妹去拍的裙子的话看一下长度
他这个侧边也看一下哈
侧边也不会很膨
不会很膨
不会像大家想象中的像这种整个膨起来的一个效果哈
他只是用的面料用的会比较大一点点
这裙子用的面料会用真的很大一片哈
应该是用很大一片的布料去做的一条半裙
整个上面都是这种有点自带的褶皱感的一个效果
谢谢姐妹关注我们这个款式
所以你看像主图其实官方他拍照的时候就是这样子的
这样子这样去拍的
因为裙摆真的非常大
这个裙子是一个复刻款哈
是和去年的半身裙是一样的
所以如果你去年是有买这一条裙子
今年就其实我们就可以看看上衣呀
外套啊之类的
就不用再买一样了
他这个确实和去年的设计包括他的长度啊腰围啊
基本上都是一样的
相当于是一个爆热款的一个复刻
侧边呢
是这样子的一个感觉
而且这个上衣我再多嘴一句
就是这件上衣他的这个设计嘛
不会让你觉得整个人的腰很长哈
就有时候像如果你中间填满的话
就感觉整个人上半身是很长的
那种设计我其实不太喜欢
但他这样子设计中间是有一个小缺口
两侧做一个这种像小尾巴
燕子尾巴一样的感觉
就会显得腰还是在比较高的位置
从这个位置到下面都是腿的一个效果哈
这个半身裙
我们看一下连衣裙的一个感觉哈
这个是连衣裙的一个效果
连衣裙我去年是就是买的这件粉色
但是我确实
但我确实是觉得这个连衣裙
他没有显瘦的一个效果哈
他这个就我穿上去也是蓬蓬的感觉
但他就要的就是这种蓬蓬的一个效果
所以如果你本身就喜欢这种比较宽大的
比较像蛋糕裙的姐妹
我感觉连衣裙也是可以入的
但如果是想显瘦的姐妹
我们就直接去拍半裙
纯纯的鞋子是什么牌子
这个鞋子的话
待会可以给大家看
给大家发一下
但我穿的像这种小凉鞋
我都是买的是那个日本的商场里的一些牌子
鞋子
这样子的一条
半裙腰围有弹力
半裙给大家看一下背后
这一圈
这么长的一个范围都是松紧
然后半裙就是S码的话
是可以穿到68左右的一个腰围
如果是67腰围的姐妹
我感觉都可以去拍S码
那68级68以上的姐妹
就可以拍M码
大概是这样子
连衣裙的话
今天反正没有姐妹点
我们就先放后面
先放后面
因为前几次也是把连衣裙
我们小鱼有在的时候
也有上升过好几个颜色
这款连衣裙反正
就也是做工很大了
但是它确实是不显瘦
二码比一码裙长三厘米
一般就是基础的腰围会大三厘米
然后裙长也是长三厘米
大概就是这样子
推荐什么颜色
半裙的话我还是推荐粉色一些
因为如果是白色的半裙
首先它裙长比较长
你白色会比较心疼
它容易弄脏
我真的觉得像这种长裙
你像上楼梯或者是走出门
鞋不小心碰了一下
我就会很担心会脏
所以我个人还是会推荐
有颜色的这样子一个半身裙
连衣裙容易皱吗
不容易
我去年反正买的粉色
我都是把它
比如说这样子叠三道
叠三道再一对折之后塞到洗衣袋里
去洗的
也没有刻意去怎么注意它
它本身就是有这种
竖着的打篮式设计
所以这个自带的褶皱之外
它是不会有其他的褶皱
这个是15号的一个连衣裙
这一件我们就剥掉了
就给你感受一下
这一件
这个很小
这个是50块钱
这一件
是很简单的
这个是10块钱
是一个很便宜的
就是一台
那个它据我看
在买的时候
你也会感受一下
这一个
这个其实也是
我每次去泡沫
也是会觉得
我都会觉得
这个我觉得
这个一个
这么便宜
打炮就好
这个
这一个
怎么腰带也没有
所以还挺
还有一点麻烦
这个刮脖小上衣
连衣裙158
长度能穿吗
158穿连衣裙的话估计有点长啊
单穿半裙也有点长
所以大家就好去配一个小高跟
或者像我一样
夏天我比较喜欢穿
松高鞋
就是厚底鞋
厚底鞋会比那种小高跟要稍微的
稳一些嘛
高跟的话还是适合想要去拍照的时候穿
但你日常其实穿舒适鞋子
穿到的机会会比较多一点
这件是不是刚才有姐妹点名的一个这个白色的小
刮脖看看是几号链接来着
是
几号链接
刚才6号对
6号的这个款式
还是一个
小刮脖
然后他的刮脖呢
有一根腰带但这个白色腰带不知道到哪里去了
所以
我们顶
脖子这一块也有两根飘带飘带的话你可以系在前面
系成蝴蝶结
也可以在这个脖子背后
头发下面
系一个蝴蝶结所以这个款式就是可以穿的方式也挺多
你不系腰带的话
就会有一点点像那种
度假系列的一个
这样子的A字上衣了
还有另外几个颜色给大家看一下哈
其实每个颜色都非常好看
他这个款式不是那个印度棉
不是印度棉
而且就
感觉氛围感也是和印度棉是完全不一样
印度棉上次做的就会有一点像那种手工
手艺人做的一个感觉对吧
但像这个款式呢整个就是比较现代化
现代化一些
那种复古感再就是
很适合ol平时上班的时候穿
但他这一个款式是都没有内衬的
都没有内衬大家需要注意一下如果你觉得很透的话
我们里面一定要穿一个那个
平平领的我胸在里面
你看我说的
腰上的绑带就是这一根这个是系在腰上但是白色的样品
他的腰带就不见了
所以我们要不要看一下
穿一个绿色的
或者是粉色呢
这个款式
穿白色也可以啊但白色我们就只能拿
这两个颜色的腰带给大家稍微记一下看看
也行
影响不大
问题不大就是颜色有点对上
但是问题不大
看看大家有没有
问题没问题的话
我们就去试穿一下
白色的小上衣咯
这个白色小上衣我还是挺喜欢但他肯定会有一点透啊
肯定肯定会有一点透
所以里面是一定要穿好大地在里面这是6号链接
整个面料的话就也是这种比较类似于雪纺的一个面料
非常清透非常凉快
其实
虽然印度棉已经很凉快了但是这一个款式
这款式的话
他毕竟不是那种
持新的嘛
他肯定是要比印度棉的那些系列要更加凉快一点点
这个款式我们去试穿一下大家稍微等我一下
特别古典的
代替
确定的
也
对
给大家再看一下
就是我换了一件半身裙之后的一个上衣的效果
一号上衣我们最后再露一下镜头
露出一下镜头
就给大家过掉
我本来是想上面直接换成我们的六号上衣的
但是我感觉这件上衣就是搭配包臀裙也非常好看
你看搭配包臀裙的一个效果
就会显得腰很瘦
这个款式上衣是绝对不会热的
如果是热的上衣
大家看我直播比较多的姐妹应该每次都会听到我说有一些上衣我觉得太热了
可能只有在室内非常凉快的情况下才可以穿
但像我现在身上这款上衣是真的室外的情况
我身上的裙子是几号链接
身上的这一条裙子也是一个已经上架的一个现货款
我看一下
10号链接也是10号链接
它虽然是我们的早下款
不算是这个下中的款式
但我感觉这个款式就是仅次于绸缎裙
绸缎裙其实都有一点点
不算是这个下中的款式
但我感觉这个款式就是仅次于绸缎裙
绸缎裙其实都有一点点
会有点像那种晚宴式的裙子
但这个款式它是西装裙
西装半身裙
所以你上面穿衬衫也可以穿这种
针织穿短袖都可以
就会比绸缎裙要稍微再正式一点点
这件的话我们去换成6号的一个上衣
给大家再重新讲一下半裙
给大家看一下这个不同的搭配
我们去换6号的一个挂裤的小上衣
6号的话白色是真的会有一点透啊
幸好我今天穿的是一个蕾丝制的这种小内搭
所以透出来也问题没那么大
但如果大家平时穿的话就性量还是
这个三件套也给我一下
每个图就是这个
对
这个结果就往下
这个好
对对对
这个很好
最后
这个好看
这个像
它像一个小对
它像一个小燕子下摆一样
特别好看
看一下
6号的小上衣和10号的半身裙
这个上衣是真的有点透
然后今天我把
蝴蝶结给它系到前面来了会稍微可爱一点点
待会我再把蝴蝶结给它系到后面去大家就可以对比一下就是
不同的一个系法的一个效果
看一下
6号链接的小上衣
6号链接我刚才有说
白色它这个样品的小
丝带也不知道到哪里去了
应该是
落在其他的地方
我们先看一下它不系
中间腰带的一个效果就是会比较类似一种
长口类的A字形
这个款式刚才有说过会比较透但是它的优点也是
就是比那种印度棉系列要更加的轻薄一些
这个肯定就是有利有弊啊它透就是反之就会更清凉一点点
半裙是粉色对是粉色非常浅非常嫩的一个粉对吧
这个款式它会比绸缎裙要稍微的日常一点
我不是说绸缎裙不日常啊但是
绸缎裙毕竟它是反光的一个面料嘛
跟这种雅光质的西装裙还是会
有很大的不一样
上衣的话蝴蝶结是需要自己去系的哈
蝴蝶结
它可以系在正前方也可以你这样子稍微歪一点
因为像很多日本女生她会比较比较喜欢这种歪歪的一个蝴蝶结的一个效果
但是歪歪的它毕竟不能固定所以
所以你拍照的时候就得偶尔去给它这样摆弄一下这个是第2种系法
那第3种系法的话就是在背后像那种
小玛丽猫一样的感觉
我们在脖子后面给它系上一个蝴蝶结
绸缎裙穿的是0码
他们家我穿的都是0码
绸缎裙
如果是012的话那我穿的应该是1码
我有点忘记了我等一下看一下
绸缎裙是012还是
012那我穿的是1码
那我穿的0码是
0码是XS的吧
那我穿的是1码
你要觉得有一点点微紫的话就是
是的
我平时穿的都是1码
0码的话就真的有点小
这个是系在背后的一个效果
系在背后的效果会比较姐姐风一点点
姐姐风的话就是Alliance他们家
他们家的工作人员会比较喜欢的一个风格
好
然后腋下可以看一下腋下不是很露就主要还是透度会比较
透一点点
我把这个粉色的
绑带先拆下来借用一下
他这个白色大家收到的时候是一个衣服和一根绑带一定要进行
检查一定要进行检查如果发现有缺失的话就
我们会立刻找他公司去要他
这个小绑带给他寄一下
寄一下其实和上一期
那个Alliance的就是
印度棉那个系列
他有一件粉色会有一点像但上一期会更加的
怎么说更加的度假一点
这次的会比较现代化
现代化的话就是整个设计会主要
偏向简约风
像那种就是比较偏度假感的他就是这里掉一些
掉一些球球啊那里掉一些那种棉质感的小
小挂饰啊像这个款式就是整体是比较
简约的
推荐薄荷色吗
其实我三个也是
都还挺喜欢主要我没怎么买过薄荷色啊
但他这个薄荷色是好看的是真的很好看
这是很清透的一个薄荷色
他不是那种实心的一个薄荷
裙子好好看
谢谢纯真不客气对这个裙子是我刚刚发现就很没什么姐妹
经常看我们直播间能看到的一款裙子
这个裙子其实是
这是5月下旬的就已经上了一条这个西装裙
我把那个
裤子拿过来给大家看一下大家就知道这一条裙子是哪一个裤子的一个同款
我把那个裤子拿过来给大家看
大家能秒速懂吗
秒懂是哪一条裤子的同款
那条裤子卖的倒是挺多的
卖的比较多但是裙子的话其实
嗯面料
反而更
好危险
这裤子大家应该看到比较多吧
这一条西装裤啊
他出了一个有一点点像同款系列的一个西装裙但是
颜色上会浅一点
颜色上会浅
也不像那个绸缎裙一样那么
浓的一个粉色啊他这个粉就是淡淡的
淡淡的
然后裤子和裙子肯定是有差异的
裙子就会看上去更加
更加淑女一点点对吧
裤子就是很
女强人的一个感觉
这个裙子
蝴蝶结可调解是吗对蝴蝶结就是你可以系在背后也可以系在正前方
我们可以自己
自由去选择
蝴蝶结是自己可以去系的
裙子容易皱吗不容易这个裙子他是西装裙
是西装裙
就是完全不会皱的程度
真的是你平时就算把这一条裙子
我们去叠着去放置啊我觉得也不会皱
他就是一个西装裙
整个都是这种西装面料
这个款式是直接有现货的我们来讲一下这款扮裙吗这款扮裙我是打算再
配一些其他的上衣给大家看一下
而且主要是
主图上都显示的是黑色大家就没有看到这些
其他颜色
我感觉如果是黑色的话我肯定不会去买啊
他这个裙子如果是纯黑色
就会有一点太正式
真的会有点太正式
但如果你刚好缺这种比较包臀的直筒的一个
黑色西装裙的话
也可以去买
这个是10号链接我们来按一下讲解
我们来按一下10号链接的讲解
这一款裙子其实配上这种比较长款的一个小上衣也可以啊
就这样你可以稍微遮一下小屁屁的一个感觉
就相当于是
如果不太喜欢裤子的姐妹下面我们穿一个简约版的一个半身裙
我们今天其实绸缎裙也在现场
但是绸缎裙的这个
风格还是大大不一样
绸缎裙稍等我找一下
绸缎裙
谁把我的绸缎拿走了
没有人拿走
而且说实话我感觉绸缎裙会稍微长一点
会稍微长一点它的下摆处也不太一样
下摆处你看它是有一点弧度的其实
绸缎裙是稍微会有带一点点小鱼尾的
不知道以前买过的大家有没有感受到它下摆处其实
有一点点小鱼尾
但是不像那种雪纺啊什么的面料鱼尾那么明显
会稍微有一点小鱼尾
而且表面是有光泽感
但是这个西装裙
就是日常
上班通勤
肯定可以穿到
绝对绝对可以穿到
这个颜色上就可以选稍微嫩一点的这种浅粉色真的很嫩
但它这个粉色是有一点偏暖色系的并不是冷色调的很
我这样低头看的话也是会
有一点点偏那种暖色调的一个感觉
上衣的话就可以真的随便搭了
感觉搭我身上这一件小
有点偏度假红的也可以
我们还可以搭一些稍微
稍微要正式一点的这种衬衫啊
比如说你就是想上班穿
我们就是想上班穿那可以搭这种
很OL风的一些衬衫
给它扎到裙子里去穿
像这个裙子版型就很
正非常正
也不会显得屁股很大
它就非常非常正
正正的版型
穿得很正式我们可以上面搭一些这种
安量斯加
而且像这个半裙啊还可以搭之前
很火的那个木耳边的一个衬衫
对不对
前几期还总是有姐妹去问的就是安量斯加也有一个
V领的木耳边有点像小玉花的那种衬衫在里面
半裙的话我们还有另外的几个衬衫
这个颜色给大家看一下
这个半身裙另外几个颜色
都还挺好看
半裙还有一个白色
纽结上衣白色是穿了吗
还没有纽结的上衣是我们今天链接里的那个款式对吧
就是这一块有一点点小扭住的一个感觉
像这个白色的话也非常正式啊
他这个西装面料就如果你之前有买过安量斯加的
裤子的话
他这个裙子的西装面料和裤子是一样的
穿在身上是非常非常版正
其实安量斯加做这种西装系列
外套裤子和裙子是做得非常好
他本身就是做这种OL通勤风起家的嘛
后来
后来才慢慢做一些那种
度假风系列
还有一个
这个是深棕色就是有点偏向巧克力色的一个感觉的
裙子
再就是纯黑色纯黑色就是我们主涂上的颜色
非常的打工服的一个感觉
当然如果你纯黑色搭的好的话其实也会
很有那种港区
OL的感觉
纯黑色
纯黑色其实搭
白色上衣好看
这个还挺日系的倒是
就是上衣会比较透
可以搭一些其他的一些白色衬衫在上面
这个是纯黑色
但这个裙子我们要讲的是他可能腰围上没有那个绸缎裙那么友好
因为
大家都知道安量斯的西装系列就是腰围还有胸围什么的他是基本上是
定好了就没有什么太大的弹力
所以这一款
他的腰围没有那个绸缎裙那么友好
也可能是他这个没卖那么多的一个原因
确实绸缎裙就可以拉的比较大但是这个款式就顶多拉开这么两三厘米就
顶天了
大概是这样子
裙子再站远一点看一下
我的脚踝倒是都遮住了背后是有一点点小开叉
有一点
背后有一点点小小的开叉
这个裙子就给大家过掉了
那个纽结上衣目前还没有试我看一下我给你拿出来看一下
是不是你要看的款式
今天有一件纽结
上衣
应该是你说的是纽结上衣吧
是这一件吗
这一件吗
是这一件吗就是左边会有一点点像这种
褶皱一样的感觉
不知道姐妹说的是不是这个小上衣
这件小上衣的话他其实官方也是就是拿出来穿
我们今天到目前为止穿了好几件
就不需要扎起来穿的一个上衣
我们都直接这样拿出来穿
他们家就拿出来的上衣就非常考验下半身穿什么
就下半身一定要穿那种
质量又好
又简单的一些系列啊
如果你下面穿特别花就不配这些
配不上这些拿出来穿的这种简约式上衣
是不是这一件姐妹
看一下如果是的话我们待会去穿一下这个
有点也不算纽结吧有点褶皱感的一个上衣
然后今天三件套也在现场也可以给大家重新再穿上去看一下
今天有个三件套还是挺漂亮的
看看还有什么想看的我们把之前没有穿过的款式都稍微过一下
这个身上我倒是一次都没有穿过所以我是打算配上我现在这个穿的
10号链接的半身裙配在一起看看
这件小上衣
他整体也是面料做得非常清透啊
我感觉如果你平时上班穿衬衫穿的比较多的姐妹一定要去选阿尼昂斯的衬衫
就是有很多牌子嘛很多牌子
就哪个牌子应该买哪一种风格我觉得大家应该都还比较摸透了
反正阿尼昂斯家他肯定是最适合上班穿的一些衣服
你看他这个衣服也很透啊
但是日常生活穿其实穿那种带胸垫的小背心是最方便
我现在每次直播都
都会穿雷索
可以四肢的内衣啊或者是带胸垫的那种小背心啊
这样就以防有一些衣服特别透的情况下我们可以稍微去
遮挡一下防止走光
我们接下来去穿一件这个小衬衫的稍微等一下
稍微等我一下
好
響鐘
而且像這個半裙就不怎麼透
主要還是因為它裡面是有一個內襯在裡面
就有一些西裝的褲子啊
或者半身裙很容易透的那種款式的話
其實就夏天穿的還挺不方便
因為還需要穿上一件衣服
然後再自己去疊加一些那種打底褲在裡面啊
所以我還是比較喜歡
如果是能自帶打底
那當然是自帶打底的款式是最方便的
但如果實在沒有自帶打底的款的話
就也只能說是自己稍微配一個
這件小上衣就配上這個西裝裙
這個款式就非常的OL風了
也就是俗稱牛馬風
但也不是牛馬這個詞
牛馬風應該也不是什麼特別差的詞
高端牛馬
看一下這一件
這件反正它的主圖上
這個
工作人員阿娘子的PR
她又沒有塞進去穿
但我是覺得
我身上的這款襯衫是值得去塞進去的
因為拿出來它其實下擺沒有像剛才那些款式那麼多設計
所以這個款式還是可以塞到褲子裡
或者是塞到裙子裡去配一下
塞進去的一個效果也
因為整體襯衫會比較薄嘛
所以塞進去你不會這裡說是鼓鼓囊囊的一個感覺啊
這件的話不想進蝴蝶結的姐妹
就可以稍微的打一個結
這樣
上衣是棕色的嗎
對
上衣但我感覺它會有一點偏棕紅色啊
有點那種棕紅棕紫的一個感覺
但是選項的話應該是選棕色
肉眼上看你會覺得它這個棕色裡面會泛著點那種
很暗的一個暗紫色的感覺
肉眼上看也是
會有點那種暗暗的感覺
暗的一個暗紫色調啊
所以這個顏色還挺顯白的
像這種暗紅色啊
酒紅色啊
暗紫色啊
對於黃皮來說都是比較顯白的顏色
側邊看一下
腋下稍微有一點點
稍微有一點點
但也不是那種特別低的一個腋下
前面的綁帶因為很大很長啊
所以如果你是想要去寄蝴蝶結的姐妹
也是
完全可以寄一個小小的蝴蝶結在前面
但我看官方它這個款式就沒有什麼寄蝴蝶結的一個效果
所以
我稍微的寄一下給大家看一下
我覺得它這個款式應該還是主要是
寄成那種像絲巾一樣
就寄一道
寄一道這樣掉下來兩根
這樣會看著稍微成熟一點
比蝴蝶結肯定是要成熟多
這是今天也是前幾次沒怎麼穿到過的顏色啊
穿到過的顏色和款式
我把另一個顏色也拿過來給大家看一下
它還有一個顏色
看看啊
還有一個顏色在哪裡呢
這個款式還有一個顏色
不在去了
好吧
它還有一個顏色今天沒有在現場啊
但今天
有一個款式前幾次總是有姐妹說想看的一個上衣
這一款是有在現場
它這件又是那種不需要去扎在
褲子裏扎在下半身裙子裏的一個上衣
它這個款式呢下擺處
做的有點像那種
裙擺的一個感覺有點像上衣裙
所以這個款其實它官方是搭配了一個半身褲的
但如果你還是不喜歡不太喜歡
那個西裝褲的話
我們也是可以穿這種包臀裙啊
和那個綢緞裙啊
就可以
看大家平時穿褲子機會多還是裙子機會多
這件也是今天一會要穿的一個新款
它當然這一件
它會有一點厚
還是會有點厚
我覺得
最近的天氣應該梅雨季都過了對不對
天氣變得特別熱了
所以我們盡量還是夏天
能買薄一點的衣服
就去買薄一點的衣服吧
還是
雖然大家平時都在這個空調房裏啊
但是真的是現在
氣溫是越來越高了
身上上衣是幾號
我來看一下
剛剛結束將近12號鏈接
12號的鏈接
它就是跟我身上穿的效果有點不太一樣對吧
因為它沒有扎進去
但是我把
這個上衣的下擺給它扎在裏面了
看上去就會有一點點不太一樣
還有像這個小上衣我們還可以搭配
它的
這一期出了一個
綢緞半身裙
大家有印象吧
這次出了一個綢緞半身裙
但
它會比上一期的綢緞半身裙要稍微的複雜一點
稍微的有設計感一點
就是這一左邊
它是像有一個胯一樣的感覺啊
有一個大飄帶大寶帶一樣的感覺
給它飄出去
反正就有一些姐妹說是特別愛這一期的一個半身綢緞裙
但我感覺喜歡簡約派的女生還是會選擇經典的那款綢緞裙
所以我們今天是兩款綢緞裙都給大家稍微穿上去
對比一下這樣子可以
看清楚到底選哪一款是選經典款還是選我們的這個
新升級版本
但這個升級版本它還有一個
特色就是
它的
胯
胯的部分
是可以給它拆卸的
可以給它拆卸
就相當於你擁有了兩條裙子的感覺
你看把它拆了之後它其實是會有一點點像經典款的那款綢緞裙
就比較素一點
所以像拍照的時候我們可以把那個胯給它圍上去但是平時
上班啊什麼的
就可以把胯整個給它拆掉
這就相當於是一衣兩用的一個效果
這個款式
我們在接下來還有一個款也
也挺想給大家再
重複的去穿一下我們先
稍微等一下我去換一下這個小上衣
上衣這款新款
沒有穿過的新款上衣還是一定要給大家補一下講解這樣
以防有些姐妹想買
但是沒有看到我們上身的視頻
但這個我覺得是有一點厚的
所以不是我本期的一個主推款
就會有一點厚
大家能接受的話你還是可以拍的
我去換一下下一套
稍等
好
但是这款上衣上身的效果很有那种买手风格
这很酷
这款上衣上身的效果感觉比想象中的好看一些
我都没有穿过这种风格的一个小上衣
是不是感觉上身之后
就是现实生活中看到可能会觉得这个人很有气质
很会穿很时尚
这一件小上衣也是我第一次穿
跟刚才穿的那个挂脖又有点不一样
这件它不是挂脖
它实际上就是一个无袖的一个背心
就基础的款式是一个无袖款
跟挂脖还是有一点区别的
因为挂脖的话
你正常去穿这个肩带的胸衣
它是一定会露出来的
这件有点厚
对这件我觉得是有点厚
所以还是
大概30度还是可以穿
你要是35、6度肯定会觉得有点厚
不知道为什么它是7月中出的
30度就是最近的这个天气
像今天东京大概是31、2度
我感觉还是可以穿的
当然你在室外很晒的情况下还是会有点热
它这个明显就变时薪了
刚才我们穿的那个小挂脖多透
我看一下那个挂脖在哪儿
刚才6号的这个挂脖
你看它材质上就不太一样
我觉得像这个13号
它官方照的照片也有一点秋冬感
所以不明白它为什么这件是7月中旬上的款式
但你说实话秋天也很难去穿无袖了
说真的
所以这个款式它可能就是属于一个天气很暖和
又可以露手臂的款式
所以这个时候去穿的一个款式
主播喜欢他家棕色
棕米色还是白色
是哪个款式
是我身上这一件吗
宝宝是我身上这一件吗
这一件
这个颜色上都是真的很漂亮
而且领口处做的像是一个小丝巾
小围巾一样的效果
你看它这个领口是身上
那我喜欢这个颜色
喜欢我身上这个棕色
棕色就会显得整个衣服
它因为整个衣服版型
你看版型是这种很A字型的一个版型
就很宽松
所以棕色的话它会压着你的身材
会看着比较瘦一点点
这个会不会显小肚子
我给你看一下侧边
不会
因为胸这里其实是会顶起来这件衣服的
你看我现在把肚子挺起来
挺着也不会觉得显小肚
所以棕色的话
肯定是会比白色浅色系要稍微显瘦一点点
这件我是比较推荐这个棕色
这个棕色的话你配裤子也好看对吧
腋下的部分也看一下
腋下没有走光
它不会做的很低
再就是肩带
刚才我说过这款它不是一个挂脖款
所以肩带的部分不会露出来
不会露出来就是一个无袖
是一个无袖
太适合穿它家
谢谢姐妹
其实他们家主要是
比较的这个简约风
我感觉大家穿上去都会很显气质
就太简约了
像这种简约风其实最考验的是它这个衣服的一个剪裁
这个好还是6号好
我会比较推荐6号一些
因为6号你是确确实实夏天能穿到
很多次的
就天气一热
我觉得大家想穿的
内容都会有一点点不一样
像这个款式它版型确实是好
但如果你放在9月份的话
9月份我们再看这件衣服可能
穿到的次数就会比6号要多了
所以这个版型吧
和它的厚度大家还是要多多去考虑一下
这件我们搭配那个
看看
搭配别的半身裤也好看嘛
它应该有一个官配的半身裤
但今天好像不在了
在现场
没有在现场看到
所以
像搭配这种比较干净一点
比较简单一点的白色系的裤子
给大家看一下
搭配这种白色的西装裤也会显得很高档啊
我觉得这个手上我们都可以拎一个小马
就是看着非常非常显气
虽然我这个衣架子还在里面看着有点诡异啊
就反正这个上衣它是
可以直接搭一个裤子在下面
包包的话我们就可以拎一些那种真皮的一些包
看着整个人都很显气质
今天有纽结上衣吗
宝宝纽结上衣是
看的很贵
他们家衣服主要是真的
你要是质量做的很差的话就感觉没有
那么显贵气的
纽结上衣是哪个款式呀
还是喜欢纽
纽结上衣
我都有点
我去问一下
纽结上衣就是你身上的这个款对吧
对对对就是这个
可以可以天呐
纽结上衣给大家看一下
我在想了半天我一看小鹿
我一看小鹿是这一款纽结上衣吧
对吧
这个款式
看一下啊
这个前几次我们穿了好多次了
穿了至少三次
但黑色我还没穿过好好看
是这个吧
对对对应该是这个大家刚刚一直一直在说我一下子脑子当机没有想到
一下子没有想到太好了太好了
一套的只有黑色
然后上衣的话有
白色
对对对我感觉大家还是喜欢收腰的
那其实还是喜欢收腰
收腰的确实显瘦呀
白色只有
上衣在
裤子没在
就一套的话现在只有黑的在
好看
你觉得黑色好看吗
腰围漆衣可以穿白色吗
可以这个是
全松紧的
这是上面那个白色好像上衣是白色是吧
嗯好像是白色
这个
腰部是难得的全松紧
好漂亮
而且黑色就显得肚子那很瘦
白色裤子离形不敢穿
白色裤子离形
但像这个款式啊
它这个还挺适合离形
对对对
因为它是直筒裤
是的
上衣也可以穿S吗
腰围71的话
我看看这个地方
这个都是S的吧
腰围
它其实真正腰的地方它是松开的
它其实这个地方是下胸围
就是下胸围这个地方
你量一下
胸围吧
我觉得姐妹还是看一下胸围
下胸围
胸围这个地方它是
有点敞
微敞
胸围其实也没有限制
就是你摸
内衣下面三公分这个地方
这个地方确实是有一点紧
就是它这个
扭结的这个地方
我把这个扭结的相冰色穿一下
就是这个这个地方如果
我现在不知道我多大
但是但是这个地方
下就是
内衣然后往下数三个手指这个地方
你可以量一下
然后跟客服说一下
然后看看是哪个
如果要是胸比较大下胸围比较大的话
那你可以选稍微大一点吧
是的
我的话因为
我也不知道我下胸围多少
但是胸围的话大概82
下胸围那也得70多吧
反正我目前觉得这个地方
对我来说还好
168、108适合几码
宝宝这个还是得要看你的
下胸围
其实这件衣服几乎没有什么别的地方有限制
就是纯下胸围这块有限制
我感觉你这个地方如果在75以上的话
那你就选
你就选
大一码
75以下的话
应该是可以选S嘛
它就是
腰围没限制
然后胸围没限制
只有下胸围这个地方
稍微有一点点限制
然后淳淳去给大家穿
咖色
好
你怎么出个街
好可爱
你妹妹今天不来
对吧
带她就不能选了
就是她
就是因为伤口
其实她现在说得很好听
就是一直疼
她昨天还跟我说
她说你不要看她的表面
她其实就是
相当于是你烫过一次
就再也不能再去
一年内就是你再也不能跳啊
再也不能爬
还是很伤口
对
所以你还是做护理吧
我觉得
做护理会稍微好一点
这个是纽结的一个上衣
纽结的上衣主要是我穿
因为我的胸围就比较死了
比较小
感觉有时候会没有撑起来
这一块的一个感觉
就这一件确实是现在卖的最多的
因为我还是
照一下照片吧
感觉就前几次没怎么拍照啊
因为最近安量子出的新款太多了
有时候没有来得及有时间拍这个款式
看一下这个纽结的小上衣
这一件我知道为什么大家喜欢
这种款式
它收腰对吧
收腰的话你日常生活中就会显瘦一些
所以
像我都很少去给大家推荐那种
非常A字型的款
因为有一些完全不收腰
其实还是挺挑身材
就感觉
像那个包括15号的那个连衣裙啊
有姐妹问
说显不显瘦
她肯定不显瘦
就不显瘦
有一些款它做出来的版型
就不是为了显瘦而做的
这个是纽结小上衣的一个香槟
棕吧
就是它因为有点反光的这种感觉嘛
所以你会觉得
有点金棕金棕的
但实际上它是有点
驼色的一个效果
这个面料上表面
外面的这一面是有点丑段的面料
但是里面我们内衬
皮肤去触碰到的位置它是仰光的
它其实有点AB面的一个效果
这个纽结上衣是好看的
纽结上衣是好看的
大家主要去量一下
这一圈
我记得我上次是不是有
报过这一圈的这个
维度啊
有点忘记了
但是我们链接里肯定是有
这个维度
20号连衣裙夏天穿会热吗
我看一下20号的连衣裙
20号的这一款连衣裙之前也没穿过
我去拿过来给大家看一下
给大家看一下
这个纽结上衣就过掉了
上衣的话
如果你觉得自己离心生残
不太穿裤子的姐妹
就穿半身裙
穿半身裙
它其实胯的这个位置啊
胯部的这个位置是遮住的
遮住了前面又掉下来一座
这个
所以就这个地方远一点
我觉得没关系吧
这地方远一点反而看得整个人更
身材更饱满一点
谢谢春春不客气
纽结白色今天没有白色
黑色和
那个深棕又在
给你看一下
这个
黑色深棕和我身上这个驼色啊
它这个驼色应该写的是米色吧
官方的那个
这一件
这件就是小鹿的时候
我也会比我的再大一些再阔一些
它刚才跟我穿的码数是一样的
这件纽结
这纽结不需要自己去调整哈
然后穿的时候怎么穿呢
它左侧
左侧腋下是有一个大拉链的
这件就是夏天可以穿哈
刚才我穿的那个驼色的一个A字型上衣
我有说很厚
有点厚
就可能30度左右穿就顶天了
这个款式是夏天
特别热的时候也可以穿
看它这么薄的一个效果大家就可以感受到
实物更深吗
就跟我们
直播镜头差不多
差不多就是这个颜色
我感觉这个颜色也挺好的
因为挺深了吧
深棕色
差不多是这个颜色
背后颈部的地方有一个金色的小飙飙这样子的一个感觉
我更喜欢哪个颜色我肯定是喜欢这个驼色的
驼色的话它会显得整个人很有质感
会显得整个效果非常有质感
我有说过那个白色的裤子部分吧
有没有跟大家说过
它因为是一套嘛
它有个裤子也是这个绸缎的面料
大家想穿这个绸缎一整套就可以配着裤子一起买
但是白色有个问题就是它那个裤子的
因为白嘛
它就会有点透
它的口袋部分会有一点显出来啊
这个是白色的一个小问题
如果比较介意这个的话就可能选其他的颜色会比较合适一些
几号链接我没有拉进来这个链接
但这个链接宝宝你可以截图去找那个客服去要
这个我们卖了很多
很多件
卖了很多件了刚上的时候就已经卖了很多件
喜欢我身上这个颜色
左侧是有拉链的
不管你是瘦还是有一点点丰满的话你都需要拉这个拉链来穿脱
他的衣服的材质上是没有弹力的
就我们说是这个材质上你是没有任何弹力
这个款式
奶茶色啊原来是奶茶色啊是吗
是我身上这个颜色
没有就和这个颜色
就和我们直播镜头里的颜色是一样的
原来这个官方写的是奶茶色吗我觉得挺好看的
而且他有反光嘛有反光其实你的视觉上会感觉到这个衣服有深
有有偏
浓一点的有偏淡一点的
就整体给人的体感上会觉得这一款
衣服没有了吗
这个颜色上
不是哈哈是像奶茶色
但我觉得其奶茶色还挺
挺那个形象
真的
这个颜色你说他是驼色但他又有一点点泛着那种
那种奶呼呼的一个感觉啊确实
挺像奶茶色
这件再接好我还是拉一下链接吧
稍等
我还是给大家稍微拉一下这个链接
然后刚才问的那个联姻群稍微等一下联姻群我得
取换一下
这个上衣我卖了好多件了
这款上衣
象牙白色是好看的哈我没有说象牙白的上衣不好看
但是象牙白的裤子大家需要去考虑一下
他的裤子我说了口袋处
就是有一点会有一点透出口袋的形状
我来加一下
我马上加进来就会出现在这个21号链接里
大家可以看一下在我们21号链接
这个7月上旬的是已经是现货款
已经是现货款
21号链接
大家看一下
我们的21号链接
我来找一下20号链接的那个联姻群大家稍微等我一下
20号链接的联姻群在哪呢
20号链接
我要去找一下因为我没看到
20号链接的联姻群
20号链接我让小鹿去帮我拿
来一下
稍微等
我们先换别的吧
先换别的
别的
看一下别的
像这件小上衣我看是不是打折了呀
裤子也是米色衣
一套好看吗我觉得是的是的真的
你会穿在身上会有那种贵妇感
不知道大家喜不喜欢这种比较就是
贵气的一个感觉
我觉得米色是真的很好看
真的真的很好
要是白色一整套有在的话就给大家拿过来看一下
但我一直是记得那个白色的
裤子就口袋因为他口袋是可以插入式的
白色有点透
那口袋的形状就会在这里有一个形状
应该没有记错
然后像今天有一个打折款式是这个吧
14号链接
4号链接是
我们的一个折扣款
他这个折扣款大家如果喜欢的话也可以拍
这件小折扣款之前卖的还挺好的没想到打折了
可能是他
留的量真的还挺多的
但他这个面料上就是还挺像那种墨打棉的一个
这个面料
上衣
穿的二码我穿的是一码
一码上衣
二码的话他的横上的那个地方会稍微再
宽一点点
这一件拿过来了20号链接的一条连衣裙我们去穿一下吧
但这一条连衣裙又是那种
完全不收腰的一条连衣裙
而且他整个
整个效果就是非常非常垂非常不收腰的一个这个
连衣裙
这个20号链接
目前我拿在手上的这个厚度我觉得有一点点
有一点厚
但是我还是要上身再体验一下
因为有时候拿在手上可能你觉得重的衣服可能上身就就还好
这件小上衣会不会很短不会你说刚才打折的那一件吗会
那件是短款非常短款所以要去搭配比较高腰的一个半身裙
去
配戴一起穿
所以那件的话就大家必须要去配高腰裤高腰裙来打
小上衣是我们今天的4号链接也是今天唯一一件打那个六折的一个款
这个链接上衣如果胸围比较大
还有就是单身腰围的姐妹我还是建议大家去拍这个
二码
还是拍M码会保险一些
尤其是胸围大的宝宝们
用安量斯的款都去拍二码就行
不过这个款是还挺chill的
这件20号链接我感觉还挺chill的
就是
感觉下面可以配一个那个人字突破和草包对吧
这件
感觉比我想象中的要好看多了
他们家衣服你还是得去这个露出来的是内搭我有在尽量避免
他的露出
但是实在是没有办法这一款裙子可能也是要去配一些交叉式绑带
带了一个胸衣会比较好一点
或者直接是配那种运动式的抹胸就行
这个款
好有垂坠感真的
感觉还是要上身式有时候拿在手上你觉得好
太简单的一些款其实上身之后还是会有一点不一样
尤其是这种纯色系
像有一些反而是那种版型特别复杂的款就
感觉一眼一眼能看出来适不适合自己啊
像这种越简单
越纯色的款真的得上身式
但这个款长度也是挺长的呢
到我的脚踝整个盖住
然后整个连衣裙的话他是有内衬的
是有内衬
这款连衣裙的内衬
颜色和最外面这个有点光泽面料的
外皮是一样的颜色
但他这个上身的话不会有拿在手上那么有重量感
这件
12号的粉色搭配8号棕色看一下
12号的
粉色8号棕色
那个小上衣的对吧
8号的一个棕色
8号没有棕色在但是12号的粉当时可以给你去找一下8号我们今天
今天只有白色有在现场
绸缎半裙对吧
绸缎半裙只有白色今天有在现场
这个款是我现在身上穿的颜色其实
竟然是个豆绿色
在镜头前能看得出来吗是有点那种豆绿灰的一个效果
整个衣服是垂在下面
左边腋下有拉链就这个拉链你可以往下拉然后这样套头给穿脱
这一款连衣裙的话下面感觉可以配那种
就是花花的拖鞋或者是人字的
很鲜的那些日系的凉鞋在下面
手上就提一个
大的那种
草边篮
大的那种木篮子草边篮就非常日系的这个我感觉简直是日本
女生夏天一定会穿到的风格
对的搭配白色也可以
谢谢姐妹她好看一下
谢谢姐妹纽结是真的非常好看
入股不亏的那种款
像这个款的话
12号稍微等一下我去帮你找一下那个粉色的小上衣
这条连衣裙适合搭究竟是买吊带
吊带度假裙还是这一件吊带度假裙的话会比这个要薄
肯定是要比这个要薄
19号
多久可以买到发货啊
应该下周陆续就可以发了宝宝
我们现货款的话就
还发的还挺快的
找这个公司或者直接去
这个上场去采购采购到了之后就可以直接给大家发了
而且最近是不是海关就是稍微
快一些了
感觉上上上个月吧是不是有一段时间
就真的是被卡的还挺严的
坐等
19号衬衫我看看啊
我今天是不是讲衬衫的时候没有按错链接吧
怎么感觉我刚才那个衬衫
可以搭是可以搭但是我个人是觉得衬衫你搭那种
比较细一点肩带的会好看一些
不过不过这个衬衫还有白色啊白色其实搭上这种衣服都还挺好看
还有像我身上这个裙子如果你实在是想收腰的话
他这个腰上我们可以自己去寄一个腰带
他就会比较像那种度假裙
你稍微把它卡起来
或者拿一个那种什么
小别针给他这样子
揪起来一点哈
就是整个氛围感会不太一样
这个20号搭19号肯定可以的
肯定是可以给你搭搭看
虽然颜色没有那么全
但是还是可以搭搭看
搭在身上就是整个人也是
很有度假感小岛风
岛国
像在岛上度假一样
但是20号确实是比
刚才的那个吊带度假裙要厚
这个是肯定肯定要厚
你这个重量感啊和厚度感都不太一样和哪一件
给他扣一点
背后就这样吊着也都可以
这肯定是可以搭的
搭配
搭配新思路
是的
像这种比较简单的裙子就可以多点
带一些配饰带项链
带这种小别针带腰带啊都可以
但简简单单的搭的话就是
脚下我们可以穿那种人字两鞋人字脱两鞋然后拿一个那种草边包
都可以这个款式
这款式另外的几个颜色
我给你拿过来看
另外几个颜色有点太
深了
太深了
反正这个款式因为不是属于
是最凉快的那种连衣裙啊所以
这两个深色系大家就可以看着入吧
如果你能接受夏天穿这么深的颜色又有一点点
重的裙子的话就也可以买这个深色
这左边是一个军绿色
右边是一个这个深黑色纯黑
背后的话就没有什么其他的设计
这个裙子还是整体走的是简约风
所以我可能还是更喜欢刚才
那个度假风的一条连衣裙吧
就今天一开播
第一套的那一件孔雀兰的一个连衣裙那一件我会更喜欢一些
像这一件的话就有点太简约了
我们就过掉咯
粉色12号粉色上衣稍微等一下我待会去帮你找一下好不好
这个12号的粉色如果今天有的话我们就刚好
待会可以配在一起
穿一下看看但如果没有的话我就下周再来穿
也没问题
下周哦对下下周是Amy的一个展会
要跟大家提前预告一下我们Amy有一个展会是在7月23号
大家可以没有加我们群的宝宝们可以加一下
12号的粉色没有在宝宝们
12号的粉
竟然没有在
像上一期啊
不知道上周直播有没有发现
这个粉色
上周有介绍一个没看到
我个人还挺喜欢也是已经是现货版的吊带裙这个也可以配19号连接的那个衬衫
这个吊带裙大家可以去搜一下我们上周有
讲解也有试穿好几个颜色啊它这个是自带充电
这点我觉得太方便
纯铸了
他自己
既简约但是会比我身上的会稍微要正式一点
我身上这个毕竟是一个A字型大伞裙
所以它像这种直
你看它里面有一个大胸垫
就你不用穿任何内衣
就可以直接套上
套上之后我们再搭配19号的那些衬衫外套
就也可以搭到一起去看
就还挺好看
这个款式
它整个面料都是和那个半身裙
绸缎裙是一样的面料
包括颜色上也是一样
所以这个还是我挺推荐的一个款
我们这个款就给大家剥掉了
我们再把实
我看看
这一件好像
虽然今天没什么姐妹点
我们今天还是把这个款式给大家稍微穿一下
还是稍微穿穿看
穿穿看我们的
我们的
刚才的
像大家今天还有什么想看的款式
都可以在我们直播间说一下
但我们今天的款其实没有特别多了
就还勉强够我们直播吧
我们把15号的绫裙给大家穿上
我觉得现在这款连衣裙的那个卖出去的销量没有
谢谢蠢蠢不客气
这个连衣裙好像确实没有二号链接的半身裙卖的好
可能还是因为没有收腰
没有那么显瘦吧
但我们还是去穿一下
如果比如说骨架子比较小
或者是你本身就比较喜欢这种蛋糕泼泼裙的姐妹们
可能我还是个人还是比较担心的
比较推荐这一件
因为这件是我自己真的入手的
二号链接我没有入手
是因为我觉得连衣裙和半身裙价格看着好像差不多
所以就买了这个连衣裙
这个连衣裙是去年就买
结果去年买了之后
因为是快接近九月份买了
就也没穿过几次
没想到今年就直接是复刻了
还挺意外
十五号的连衣裙
我们去给大家穿一下
稍等
他这个连衣裙用的面料非常之大
非常之多
就可能用了好几米的这个布料来做
但主要我自己个人是比较喜欢这种比较偏甜系偏公主系的一些裙子
所以我可能还是很喜欢这件连衣裙
但是他的缺点就确实是不显瘦
不显瘦会有一点像这种你看他其实官方图
我觉得照的也算真实了
对吧
官方图十五号链接
就官方图照的也是这么蓬蓬的
像一个小蛋糕一样
对吧
这件的话就如果是骨架的比较小
或者本身就比较喜欢这种像度假裙一样
你看他的裙摆啊
真的做的非常大
做的非常大
他这个裙摆因为裙子是立体的嘛
你相当于是一整面一整圈
他得用多少的布料去做这条裙子
大家应该可以猜到就肯定是好几米啊
好几米的这个面料
去做这款裙子
就这个裙子他会把你该遮这块肯定都是遮到
但就是这一块这一块是柱状的
就不显瘦
这一件是十五号
十七号的裤子会穿吗
这件粉色冰蓝色是粉色
冰蓝色是九月上旬才出货吗
我看看我们链接啊
哎
我们链接写日七月上
是不是另外几个颜色写的是别的月份
十七号的裤子是九月上旬才出货吗
这个裤子会穿会穿十七号
大家想看什么颜色呀
这个裤子
那裤子的话
我刚才是有看到一白色的开叉开叉版的在现场
裙子的话
可以看一下这个效果
他的面料和半身裙是一样哈
然后连衣裙就是转起来的话
整个裙子会像花瓣一样
这个裙子我还是挺喜欢
我为什么去年到九月底
哎
不是
九月就是八月底快到九月的时候才买这条裙子
是因为我我有一天来他们公司直播的时候
就看到他们自己的一个日本工作人员在穿这一件
我就在想啊
他穿的真的很好看
因为那个女生她很瘦
所以我就看她背影觉得这个真的太漂亮
但买回去主要是这一款
因为是无袖嘛
其实只有夏天可以穿
还有就是她是特别漂亮的裙子啊
然后她是统状的是A字版型的
那就不太容易搭得上那个小开衫
就没办法去搭什么开衫啊
这个也是可能其中的一个小缺点
17号有粉色吗
搭配棕色上衣
我先看一下17号是下摆处有开叉的一个裤子
白色倒是在现场
看看粉色
粉色的话不在
饱了粉色今天不在
有白色你看一下
看这个白色这是17号
17号下摆处是有一个小
这个小开叉
有一点小切割
切割成这种开叉式的一个样子
这个是17号
粉色今天没有在现场
你看看白色的话
我给你搭一个棕色
棕色上衣可以吗
搭一个那个纽结上衣啊
或者是刚才
有穿过的比较 a 字版型的一个上衣
看看哦
再站远一点是不是没看到
17号的一个白色西装裤
这一件
这件今天又在白色是又在西装裤
而且这个17号
他后半圈竟然是有松紧
像其他的很多西装裤
其实后半圈都没有松紧的
连衣裙胸围宽松
超级
无敌宽松
就基本上是不限制啊
s 码都不限制
s 码都可以说是完全没限制
他这个呃
连衣裙跟那一件最近刚刚很多
也不是刚刚应该收到了半个月多吧
就是风情裙
会感觉上有点像因为完全不收腰
所以腰围也不限
这个胸围也不限
怎么
你去点
这一件
158能穿吗
158可以穿
但是嗯反正可能到脚面吧
盖住脚面
我给你看一下我大概到的位置
158可以穿
但是肯定是长的
肯定是长
这这款裙子我穿也很长
所以160以下的小个子女生
其实穿也会很长
但158的话
我感觉宝宝你就可以去参观
我感觉宝宝你就可以去参考
他们的主里人中村马铭去看一下
就中村马铭不穿高跟鞋的时候到哪里
他差不多是156左右的一个身高
cap близ7号的这个姐妹
你看一下有白色在现场
如果这个白色
大家不太想看的话
我们粉色只能得到好的 그만
我们粉色只能得到好的 kullan
下一次来穿
这个是15号的
17号的一个开叉式的西装裤
这款西装裤我先挂到旁边去
今天其实差不多就是这些款式
没有什么太多的新款
今天的款就这么多了
还有一个像这个裙子感觉
卖的也还挺好的
这一件
这件的话
感觉上面可以配一些白色衬衫啊什么的
它是一个蕾丝的半身
蕾丝拼接的这样子一个半身裙
也是比较类似于西装半裙
但会比西装半裙更有趣一点的地方
就是下摆处它是拼接了这么长的一串
这个蕾丝的一个效果
所以这个款式也是
会比普通的西装裙
要更加的
有这种风情感
原来下面拼接的这些蕾丝都做的很高贵
它这蕾丝会有一点那种复古的一个效果
欧式蕾丝的一个感觉
今天其实就差不多是这么多款了
大家会发现我们最近就介绍的这个直播时间会比较短
因为每一次的款就没有那么多
它每次安量次是下款
会一下子把三个月的款式全部放出来
但我们
其实也介绍了差不多有一个月左右
所以该讲的都讲到过
然后接下来下周可能就是陆陆续续讲一些Amy的款式
再就是下下周是有Amy的一个展示会
Amy展示会结束了之后
我们还会有安妞的一些展示会
大家都可以期待一下
Amy展示会这次会有一些很漂亮的一些款式
大家都期待一下
然后今天直播就
到这里结束了差不多两个小时
大家就下周再见
下周我们有Daisy的展会
大家一定记得守住我们的群
我们是Daisy展会
一定会在这个群里随时播报给大家的
拜拜
我把这个手机关掉了